hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers in games
upcoming blu-ray release features a
number of deleted scenes some of which
we just got glimpses of from a trailer
release during Comic Con in which the
film's directors and screenwriters both
spoke at Hall H and dropped a crazy
number of background details about this
movie story yet no further understanding
of the time-travel logic of their own
movie but hey if they did no one would
need utube explanations and I wouldn't
know Jeff big [ __ ] dolls I'm gonna
break down these end game deleted scenes
shown in this blu-ray trailer and what
they tell us about the alternate way the
Avengers final battle against Thanos
could have gone okay the first shot from
this trailer that was deleted from
in-game was a green screen shot of
star-lord Peter quill and the Ravagers
in the final battle against Thanos his
forces
star-lord says nobody behind Peter quill
there's crag Lin shotguns character from
the guardians of the galaxy movies he's
wearing yondu's Yakka arrow head piece
now we did see him fooling around with
that and one of the post-credits scenes
after guardians vol 2 and Sean Gunn also
posted a selfie of himself in this
costume shortly after the movie came out
crag Lin was removed from this final
battle in the final cut of the movie but
perhaps the deleted scenes will include
these kinds of unfinished versions of
him in action
the filmmakers have said in the months
since the release that a lot of things
were removed in the final battle
sequence as it was being reworked that
includes several other Avengers team-up
and reunion moments and a kind of
intermission regroup moment with all the
Avengers in a trench taking cover from
Thanos as fire and trying to strategize
what to do next
the in-game screenwriters also hinted it
alternate to very dark versions of this
final battle that they had in mind
during the scripting phase I'll explain
all those in a future episode moving on
to the next deleted scene from in-game
that we can find in this trailer shots a
black widow in battle and remember
Natasha died in this movie sacrificing
herself to give Hawkeye the soul stone
on Vermeer so overall in this movie
Natasha Romanov doesn't see a ton of
action this is because there was
originally a larger action set piece on
Vermeer in which Santos's forces meet up
with Black Widow and Hawkeye on that
planet try to get to the soul stone
before they can in a major battle ensues
now it wasn't clear if this fight was
going to be before or after Clinton
Natasha reached the mountain with red
skull I'm guessing after based on the
rock formations visible
the background behind Natasha and these
deleted shots red Co might have given
both of them D who low down on how
wonder them has to die to keep the stone
but in surprise T piano shows up and in
the midst of this battle Clint a Natasha
struggle to sacrifice themselves by
throwing one of themselves off the cliff
kind of like a game of capture the flag
where you just trying to end the fight
as soon as possible by a I guess kill
yourself or who knows maybe Black Widow
was gonna die and then Clint was gonna
show off new versions of the soul shows
powers that we haven't seen yet like
ripping a bunch of outriders changed
from their bodies and banishing them to
hell folks I can't be the only one who
wants to do more crazy [ __ ] with these
Infinity stones that just like collect
them all and snap now there were a few
more shots from the Australia that
appeared to have been deleted from
Avengers in game that I'm gonna get to
but before I continue thank you to
manscaped for sponsoring this episode we
get it it's Comic Con but that's no
excuse to let your junk cosplay as a
wookie
no that's the sound of your ball save
oxygen manscape comm is the only men's
brand dedicated to below the waist
grooming and hygiene they created the
world's first manscaping kits that makes
trimming safe and easy they got
everything you need to get started with
a simple easy-to-follow hygiene regimen
that your balls your boo and your Hall H
line buddy will probably thank you for
their perfect package 2.0 kit features
the lawnmower 2.0 waterproof manscaping
trimmer this baby's got a powerful 6,000
rpm motor and skin save technology that
means no Nick's no snags in the hardest
place in the world to bandage so hard
and if you subscribe to the perfect
package 2.0 with a peak hygiene plan
that'll deliver a new clean replacement
ceramic trimmer head right to your door
every three months if you do that you'll
save 25% from your total instantly and
as an added bonus for this peak hygiene
plan you'll get a free mystery gift
every three months in a replenishment
pack and that is in addition to the gift
of a scrotum smooth as silk and for a
limited time your purchase will also
come with a free shed travel bag and of
course all manscape products featuring a
30-day money-back guarantee so you can
try them risk-free remember if you Nick
your sacks and the back or in the
slogans that I pitched if you cut your
boys return your toys if your nuts get
shanked say no thanks if your scrotum
gets blended return to sender ok I'm
moving on your 20% off was free shipping
for your perfect package too
no purchase when you use the promo code
rockstars 20 at manscaped calm okay back
to the deleted scenes visible in this
end game blu-ray trailer a lot of this
footage is like gag reel kind of stuff
behind the scenes including what looks
like a Stan Lee tribute montage maybe
the same one that played after the end
game re-release a few weeks back but
then in a brief section marks deleted
scenes there's a quick shot of Pepper
Potts looking up surprised caught off
guard now this could be another outtake
with Gwyneth Paltrow or we could be
seeing a moment with her and maybe her
daughter Morgan before the final battle
remember in an earlier scene in the film
Morgan wears the blue stark helmet that
Tony designed for pepper which would
eventually be part of her rescue armor
Morgan said she found in the garage but
maybe Morgan will reappear in this
moment with the full armor shocking her
mom who then sees the armor and realizes
that she needs to go join the fight -
but then finally what I see is the most
fun of these deleted shots there's the
moment when the Avengers are sitting
around the table brainstorming the time
ice and Tony Stark shaves arrow and to
Crockett said yep we're shaving all
kinds of body hair this episode oh no
there's a lot to enjoy about this clip
this table is covered with various books
about quantum physics and time-travel
theory none of which the makers of this
movie probably read and over on the far
left you can see Lebowski Thor making a
drink with celery and Tabasco sauce yeah
he's making a Bloody Mary folks this is
the hangover drink that he requested
after his rambling story about Jane
Foster and the reality stone now the
filmmakers have been talking more and
more about a workout montage I would've
shown Thor getting back in shape that
was removed from the film and how Thor's
storyline and infinity war was very very
different in the scripting phase that
actually almost derailed the whole movie
more on all that in a future episode but
which of these deleted scenes do you
wish were kept in in the game comment
down below with your thoughts and follow
me on instagram at twitter at EA vas and
subscribe to new rock stars are
breakdowns of all the big updates coming
out of comic-con and of course
everything Marvel related thank you for
joining me and Russo in an in-game
bottle does it matter
as I love it 3,000
[Music]